let's say for some reason you had lent
the government one thousand dollars and
so the government has given you a
formally issued piece of paper that says
hey we the government owe you one
thousand dollars this is issued by the
treasury this could be a treasury bond
it could be a t bill of some kind and
let's say that the federal reserve the
central bank is interested in inserting
money into our system so let's say this
is the federal reserve right over here
federal
reserve
and so what they do is they create 1 000
of federal reserve notes what we
associate as paper money and they pay it
to you and they buy the treasury so that
treasury goes to the federal reserve
from you and so and in exchange you get
this newly created money that the
federal reserve just created so there
you go
you have
this is one thousand dollars now what
would you likely do with that one
thousand dollars well it might not be
safe to walk around town with your
pockets bulging like that so a lot of
folks would deposit it into a bank so
let's think about what would happen to
the bank's balance sheet so you go to
bank
bank a
and i'm just going to think about i'm
not going to think about what was the
balance sheet the pre-existing balance
sheet for the bank but let's just think
about what happens to its assets and its
liabilities when you make that deposit a
for assets l for liabilities
if you deposit those thousand dollars
then your assets for the bank
is going to get one thousand dollars in
reserves
in reserves but you didn't just give
them the money they have a liability to
you you should have a checkable deposit
account now so we could say checking
account
so now
you have a one thousand dollar checking
account which you would view as an asset
for yourself but it's a liability for
the bank at any time you could come and
ask for that thousand dollars one
thousand dollar checking
checking account
account and this would be
for you now we've already spent several
videos talking about fractional reserve
lending and there's two ways we can
conceptualize it as we've seen in those
videos but i'm going to go with the the
simpler version of fractional reserve
lending and so this bank says look we
are in a world where our reserve
requirement
i will do a reserve requirement this
actually is a typical reserve
requirement the reserve requirement
in
this country is 10
which says that the bank only has to
keep 10 percent of these cash reserves
and then it can loan out the rest and so
it does that that's its business model
or a significant part of its business
model and so what it does is instead of
having one thousand dollars in reserves
it keeps ten percent so it keeps one
hundred dollars and it loans out the
rest and so it loans out
nine hundred dollars
so it's loading out now
nine hundred dollars to someone else
hopefully someone who is good for the
money
who maybe they're going to invest into
their business or they're going to buy a
house or whatever else now once again
the bank just didn't give them the money
in exchange they get an asset which is a
an iou from that person that person owes
the bank money they owe them 900
so we could say that in exchange for
giving them that cash they're going to
have a 900
loan on their balance sheet as an asset
now once again the person that they lent
the money to the loan would be a
liability they owe the money but for the
bank that's an asset hey someone owes me
the bank 900
but then what's this person going to do
well once again their pockets aren't
going to bulge quite as much but they
still might not want to walk around town
with 900 in their pockets
so they are likely to deposit in a bank
and they could deposit it in bank a or
they could deposit it in another bank
let's call it very creatively
bank b
all right so bank b same exercise i
think you might see where this is going
so it's assets
it's
liabilities and so they go and they
deposit these this 900
so you have 900 right over there and the
corresponding liability you that person
didn't give the money to the bank the
bank owes can that person can demand
that money at any point from the bank
and so you have a 900
900 checking account
checking
account
and that person would drop on that
checking account to buy the machinery
for their business or whatever else but
once again we have a 10 reserve
requirement which says that the bank
only has to keep 10 percent of that and
so their business business model is they
do only keep 10 of it and then the rest
of it they loan out
so they loan out
eight hundred and ten dollars
it could be a loan or it could be
multiple loans altogether
and i think you see where this is going
and so this is lent out to someone else
so now we have eight hundred and ten
dollars which can then be deposited in
another bank bank c they can lend out
ninety percent of that and that process
keeps going on and on and on and on so
an interesting question is given this
infusion of a thousand dollars and given
this reserve requirement how much total
money has been created well in other
videos we talk about the multiple
measures of the money supply when the
federal reserve put this one thousand
dollars of federal reserve notes into
circulation they increased the monetary
base by one thousand dollars but one
measure of the monetary supply is well
what are the federal reserve notes the
coins the
the federal and the paper money that's
in circulation
plus the amount of
checkable deposits and we talk about
that in other videos as m1
and so our m1 over here what's it gonna
be
well this person has a thousand dollar
checking account one thousand dollars
checking account they think they have
one thousand dollars that they can write
checks against and they do
and this person has a 900 checking
account
900 checking account and then this
person right over here then when they
deposit their money they're going to
think they have an 810
checking account
they have that and then that process is
going to go on and on and on and on
someone else when this 810 gets
deposited the bank's going to lend out
90 of that that person is going to think
they have that amount of money and so
what we do is we're just multiplying by
.9 every time we're multiplying by one
minus the reserve requirement every time
and we've done the mathematics on this
multiple times this is going to be equal
to one thousand dollars
the initial amount that was put into the
monetary base
times
one over
one minus zero point nine
and that is just going to be equal to
1000 dollars
times 1 over
0.1 or you could just view this as 1
over the reserve requirement
it just happened to be 0.1 in this
example reserve
requirement and you could do the math on
what that's going to be 1 divided by 1
10 is going to be 10 and so our m1 money
supply that has been created in this
very simple example is going to be equal
to is going to be equal to 10 times a
thousand dollars so it's going to be
equal to 10
so big picture when the monetary base is
increased by a certain amount if you
know the reserve requirement
and if you assume that all of the banks
minimize their reserves that keep only
the 10 percent they don't keep 11 or 12
percent or 20 percent then what this
calculation is going to show you is what
is going to be the maximum effect on m1
given that infusion into the monetary
base and all it is is the amount that
was infused times one over the reserve
requirement